hello and welcome everyone to the active
inference live stream it is act imp
stream 9.1 and it is November 24th
2020 so welcome everyone to the ACT imp
stream and welcome to
teamc today in the ACT imp stream we
will be talking about a really
interesting paper so I'm quite excited
tecom is an experiment in online team
communication learning and practice
related to active inference you can find
us at our website our Twitter at email
our YouTube or our public keybase team
and shared key based
username this is a recorded and an
archived live stream so please provide
us with feedback so that we can improve
on our work all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and also
just as far as video etiquette for live
stream remember to mute if there's any
noise in your background raise your hand
so that we can hear from everybody on
the stack and use respectful speech
Behavior Etc just to quickly go through
the rest of the meetings that we'll be
having for 2020 um today on November
24th we're talking about the projective
Consciousness model and phenomenal
selfhood next week in 9.2 on December
1st we're going to be talking about the
same paper so anything that gets raised
today whether you're participating live
or watching a replay let us know about
it so we can cover it in
9.2 on December 8th and 15th in 10.1 and
10.2 we'll be discussing the paper a
variational approach to scripts and then
on December 22nd and 29th we'll be
talking about sophisticated effective
inference and that will be another more
on the modeling side paper to discuss
cool today in act mstream 9.1 the road
map will be as follows we'll start off
with some introductions and warm-up
questions and then we'll get to 9.1
we're going to be talking about the
paper called the projective
Consciousness model and phenomenal
selfhood by Williford at all 2018 and
the punchline of this paper is basically
about the combination of a few different
fields geometry cybernetics
neurophenomenology Etc and by combining
these fields under the framework of
active inference there might be
something there to understand or explain
about Consciousness so we'll go through
the aims and the claims of the authors
the abstract and the road map and then
at multiple points here and throughout
we want to take time for questions so
really anyone who raises their hand will
just as soon as we can um cut there
because it's so interesting what people
have come to mind during these
provocative topics then we'll go to the
author's study of Consciousness and talk
about the two lists that they make and
what those lists do for the paper and do
for their Theory and those are the
functional features and the
phenomenological invariance of
Consciousness and then at the end we'll
go through the figures and with however
much time we have we'll go into thinking
about what each figure might represent
or invoke and as stated in 9.2 we're
going to be discussing this same paper
again so save and submit any questions
you have and get in touch with us if you
want to
participate great for the introductions
and up please just introduce yourself
and your location say hello and as short
of an intro as you'd like and then pass
it to somebody else who hasn't yet
spoken so I will go first I'm Daniel I'm
in California and I'll pass it to
Alex uh I hope I'm audible my name is
Alex I'm also in
California uh and I will pass this to uh
Shannon hey I'm Shannon I would be in
California normally but I'm in South
Dakota so I'll pass it to
Lee hi I'm Lee I'm in London uh and I'll
pass it to
Mattis R currently
muted okay hi I'm Mathis I'm currently
in Germany in AAR Brook um and I passed
it to
even hello my name is vanan I'm from
Moscow Russia and I pass it to
Sasha hi my name is Sasha I'm also in
California and I'll pass it to Alex uh
V thanks hi I'm Alex I'm in Moscow
Russia and I pass it to
Steven hello I'm Steven I'm in Toronto
in
Canada cool that is everyone so great
thanks for these introductions everybody
let's do some warmup questions and
there'll be a few of them and anyone who
would like to talk just jump on with
raising your
hand let's try to hear from everyone as
well the first question and I'll do
actually the first and the second
question together since I think that
they're very related the first question
is what interests you about studying
Consciousness and this second question
is what are some ways that we can study
Consciousness um maybe someone's a
skeptic maybe they don't think that we
can study Consciousness or maybe they
have a really awesome uh idea about how
we could do that so Lee uh go ahead
what's your first
thought uh yeah so um I mean I primarily
come from the phenomenological angle and
um particularly kind of
neurophenomenology really and what I'm
really interested in is agency so can
the can the models uh that come out of
uh coming out of Neuroscience can they
help us to um increase our our agency so
for example um if you can become
reflexively aware of simulations modal
simulations that are going on in your
system then do those become affordances
for actions that we can take and so you
increase the scope of of agency so
that's kind of what really interests me
about this
cool thanks
Shannon I love that you bring up agency
right off the bat um something that's
really interesting for me about
Consciousness which I don't study at all
is when we lose our sense of agency like
when we're in flow States if we're
making music or I guess people get in
flow States if they really like
exercising and we're completely immersed
in the experim experience but not
conscious aware or we don't have the
same kind of intentionality that we do
as if maybe we're we're like writing
down a math problem or trying to speak
over a live stream and and thinking very
carefully about each of our words and I
get guess just the phenomenal quality of
those two types of experience is really
interesting to
me I agree and it's part of this what is
consciousness question and what is the
role of awareness so when we're really
paying attention to doing a task with
with our hands when we're really paying
attention to balancing on a beam or
something like that are we truly at our
most self aware at that moment or are we
at our least self-aware or in which ways
are we self-aware we're not thinking
about our biographical history per se
but in another sense we're the most
embodied and anactive sort of circuit
for Action so where is that going to fit
in with active inference and with this
idea that we are embodied in an
environment so what is yeah really more
experiential of the self doing something
that might take your whole body or bring
your full attention to bear or doing
something that asks you to write a
personal statement something like an
autobiographical or narrative self cool
if anyone else wants to go on the first
two those are good questions or the last
question here is just like what is
another theory or framework for
Consciousness that you know of or have
heard about doesn't need to be your
theory to um support or deny here just
like what is something else that is in
the space of this paper and then what's
just something that you liked about it
or found absent from that model so all
just starts with something that I find
missing from a lot of models and I
really want to know where agency and
where a lot of other topics fit into
play here is it's often a little unclear
whether Consciousness is something that
reaches back into the system and
intervenes or whether it's something
that's just purely Epi phenomenal or
kind of um just there could be awareness
but awareness may not have causal power
so is consciousness something that's
just getting spun off to the side and
produced but not reaching back into the
system or is it something that's
actually essential potentially even in
an evolutionary or adaptive context for
maintaining coherent Behavior
Stephen yeah I'm I'm interested in in
this question of self-consciousness that
seems to be um and I like just the idea
of General Consciousness being thought
about because I think in psychology this
idea of the self and the idea of the
individual has become so dominant and
the idea of broader Consciousness was
kind of left a 100 years ago for the the
philosophers to deal with so this idea
of I have a self and I have this um idea
of a psychology and this perspective on
the psychology has become kind of
all-encompassing but now this ability to
bring Consciousness in more broadly sort
of dissolves a lot of those problems
because it it kind of stuck psychology
at this single scale analysis um so
that's one of the things I think that um
is quite exciting by all of
this cool
Sasha um one thing that I I find missing
I feel like a broken record sometimes um
is the developmental side of
Consciousness um and even if we're
thinking about
humans you know our favorite
species uh how does Consciousness
develop across a lifetime time and what
are the different uh stages or versions
of Consciousness that we pass through um
and is there sort of a developmental
trajectory because um I tend to think
it's not like flipping a light switch
think it's not that we are born and
we're immediately plugged into this um
same Consciousness that we're
experiencing today so um yeah that's
kind of what I would like to see from a
Consciousness model is different levels
or um
versions of it that we can start to
describe like much like the Flow State
or um
sleep cool
Shannon yeah I like both of those um
points that Stephen and Sasha brought up
and not just how does our our personal
Consciousness develop over time but how
does our Consciousness like our group
Consciousness um develop so like as an
infant a lot of your conscious
experience is really coupled with uh the
mother or the
caregiver and like slowly you might
develop a sense of of yourself as an
individual separate from that
caregiver but also when We Gather in
groups you know when We Gather at
concerts or We Gather at protests or in
events where
we're mix of explicitly or implicitly
interacting with each other we start to
behave like like one group and in some
sense we start to really feel like one
group rather than like just myself in a
room full of other
people yep cool and something in the ant
literature people have wondered about is
the nestmate conscious is just the
colony conscious but not the nestmate
then what is really happening with this
transition from Individual to group and
the development of that also interesting
the formation of group is it kind of
like how many sand grains make a heap
you know once there's three people it's
a collective Consciousness or do they
have to be doing contact improv or do
they have to be rhythmically sing
synchronized what are those Dynamics
what might be metrics what might be
things that we could come to the table
and agree on as far as measurements are
concerned so that we could kind of move
the needle forward in research or is
this a question that because of its
maybe fundamental difficulty in
measurements is it a question that's
sort of forever going to be in the
speculative domain I think that the
authors of this paper would suggest that
scientific study of Consciousness is
Meritus and that there's value in
approaching with even a mathematical
bent approaching how we could study
Consciousness though it's by no means
obvious that mathematics is the way that
we're going to express the language or
the structure of Consciousness
especially when we start to think about
all these different dimensions like
group versus individual and what you
know who is individual we were never
individuals that type of thinking what
does the brain region know that the
neuron doesn't and the Brain know that
the region doesn't all these questions
are going to come into play and a lot of
the the neuro and social parts are going
to get a little bit um not swept under
the rug here but this paper is clearly a
little bit more on the cut and dry
projective geometry side and there's a
lot of discussion of neurophenomenology
but you don't see any pictures of cells
you don't see any actual details of
neurom mechanisms it just assume well
you could wrap mechanisms and mechanisms
kind of close to the end uh to get this
type of A System's behavior and so we'll
get a little bit more into it so at any
point of course people are welcome to
raise their hand we'll just try to
immediately whatever Springs to mind in
a relevant moment so no worries about
these prompts let's talk about the paper
which is the projective Consciousness
model and phenomenal selfhood by
willford at all in December 2018 in
Frontiers in Psychology theoretical and
philosophical
psychology the aims and the claims of
the paper are basically as such they ask
can we describe this integrated
multimodal and centered spatial
structure of conscious experience in a
rigorous way and can we give a good
account of why it should be thus
organized here we answered both
questions in the affirmative great big
if true let's see these be answered
overall the PCM delivers an account of
the phenomenologically available generic
structure of Consciousness and that
speaks to Steven's Point about the
general Consciousness and shows how
Consciousness allows organisms to
integrate multimodal sensory information
memory and emot in order to control
Behavior enhance resilience optimize
preference satisfaction and minimize
predictive error in efficient manner and
this is again to my earlier point about
does Consciousness get spun off of the
system or does it reach back in so does
Consciousness control behavior and
enhance resilience or is that systems
with controlled behavior and enhanced
properties like resilience do those
systems spiral off Consciousness as an
observer that's vague here but the way
that we phrase these sentences is is
essential it's like active versus
passive mistakes were made versus I made
a mistake versus you made a mistake
pretty different and the non uh jargony
way might be to ask how can we apply
active inference as this unifying
framework to the study of Consciousness
in all of its unified coherent
mysterious Dynamic and profound facets
and we'll see when they get to the
functional features and the
phenomenological invariance which
aspects of Consciousness they think are
sort of the key features to explain uh
and really integrate across into one
common framework so that's what we hope
to be getting at today even though this
paper is not the whole citation Network
we're definitely going to be exploring a
lot of the key ideas and questions about
how and where active inference and the
free energy principle could link back to
Consciousness so here's the abstract
briefly they write we summarize our
recently introduced projective
Consciousness model PCM which is rud at
all 2017 and relate it to outstanding
conceptual issues in the theory of
Consciousness the projective
Consciousness model combines a
projective geometrical model of the
perspectival that means from a
perspective phenomenological that means
what's experienced structure of the
field of Consciousness with a
variational free energy minimization
model of active inference comma yielding
an account of the cybernetic that means
goal-seeking function of Consciousness
viz the modulation of The Field's
cognitive thought processes and
affective like how it feels emotions
Dynamics for the effective control of
embodied agents another uh plus one for
affective and effective in the same
sentence abstract part two the
geometrical and active inference
components are linked via the concept of
projective transformation so we'll
definitely have a slide where we look at
what a projective transformation is
which is crucial to understanding how
conscious organisms integrate perception
emotion memory reasoning and
perspectival Imagination in order to
control Behavior enhance resilience and
optimize preference
satisfaction the PCM makes
substantiative empirical predictions and
fits well into a neuroc computationalist
framework it also helps us to account
for aspects of subjective character that
are sometimes ignored or conflated
pre-reflective self-consciousness the
first-person point of view the sense of
mindness or of ownership and of social
self-conscious so maybe we will get to
some of these social topics and they
close by saying that we argue that the
PCM though still in development offers
the most complete Theory to date of what
Thomas metzinger has called phenomenal
selfhood so that's combining this
phenomenology component with a selfhood
uh element any thoughts on the abstract
or we can move
forward bring them up during the road
map so the abstract is just the header
of the paper it's kind of like the
metadata for the ingroup and outgroup
discussion the road map is how they're
actually going to implement these kinds
of claims that are suggested in the
introduction in the abstract so first
with a more formal introduction to the
topics they discussed in the abstract
and then they went straight to
methodology which I think is very
important especially when discussing
something that's abstract like this then
they talk about the phenomenological
invariance and the functional features
of Consciousness which we'll go through
on separate
slides and specifically they talk about
these invariance in terms of a
projective geometry feature of the PCM
they talk about the functions and then
talk about how the PCM links the
function features of Consciousness
within an active inference and a
cybernetics framework so they're taking
some of the invariants combining them
with projective geometry they're taking
some of the features and combining that
with cybernetics uh in the sense of
active inference as a modern phrasing of
cybernetics and free energy minimization
as an optimization process and they're
kind of connecting experience
cybernetics projective geometry all
these different things together and
asking whether it makes sense they then
have all their four figures which we'll
go through today
that range from sort of sketch-like
accounts of psychological phenomena to
some early solutions to otherwise
challenging ideas like uh Illusions
necer Cube and then they sketch out a
few different representations and
simulations that they run or ran
elsewhere they then return to this
question of the hard problem
representationalism and phenomenal
selfhood so the hard problem is the hard
problem of Consciousness attributed to
Chalmers and others that relat to
basically where the rubber hits the road
how does Consciousness arise or what is
it I think there's many hard problems uh
and who knows which ones we think are
easy but actually are hard the point is
they're going to come at that Nexus from
a computational and a functional angle
then they talk about representationalism
in the PCM and I feel like
representationalism we've heard about a
bunch on active stream with a basian
structural
representationalism and now we're going
to come at it from a different angle
from a geometric and a cybernet angle
they then talk about how the PCM is
linked to subjective character as well
as phenomenal selfhood which is clearly
one of the things that they're out to
describe and then they conclude so
they're going to go from taking a few
different threads of phenomenological
neuro research and tie that with some
more mechanism agnostic control theory
approaches like cybernetics active
inference and optimization approaches
like free energy minimization they're
going to bring in this projective
conscious
uh projective geometry bit to tie it all
together and then we get to the
conclusions and also some of their
thoughts on where to go next so let's
just pause there I've written out a few
questions but does anyone just have a
thought or a question or when they read
the paper like what was a first thought
was there something that resonated a lot
was there something that seemed IL
defined or you would have defined it a
different way or just something you
curious about
Stephen well one thing I thought was
interesting was this idea of
perspectival Consciousness so this idea
that when you're consciously taking a
perspective on your
situation um which you normally might
think of as seeing it but it could be
some sort of embodied sense so I think
that was kind of important and there and
how that differs from maybe the
unconscious um
dynamics that are just going on that
they don't necessarily deal with so it's
somehow sitting I don't know if it's
sitting on top or sitting alongside it
but there's there's somehow this
perspectival piece that somehow kicks
in yeah and we often think about Vision
in talking about how active inference is
to be differentiated from let's just say
a sensory relay model where you know
photons come in your brain categorizes
them and makes an image and then you act
and here it's like it's a generative
model of the world that you're
experiencing that's why there's color
and good resolution around the edges and
no blind spot and then it's like well
then why do we see what appears to be
coming from our eyes or from a position
that's right there and that's where
we're going to come back to with a lot
of these questions about the projection
itself and why we appear to be situated
Lee sorry yeah hi I don't know if it's
relevant but um I was just thinking
about so the the discovery of
perspective
uh you know back in the in the
Enlightenment and I was thinking well
obviously you know if this is a sort of
a more generic Theory Of Consciousness
then um I was wondering if it connected
perhaps to met singer's idea of
transparent States so that uh you know
the projective geometry would have
always been there but they would have
been transparent and somehow you know in
the process of the discovery of
perspective uh it became something that
we were able to pay attention to more
more consciously anyway just a thought
cool I IDE let me actually unpack that
first what would you describe as the
transparent State because I don't know
of that terminology specifically what is
a transparent State here so I think in
met singer's model so transparent States
would be those states that we are that
we view the world through so we that
we're in a state but we don't know that
we're having a particular State whereas
he he contrasted to a metaphor I think
really so an know P state would be a
state where we where we understand that
it's a a um a sensory state if you know
what I mean cool the transparent State
it's kind of like what is water the
water we swim in it's like the water is
transparent so when you look out all
directions it's not being seen
specifically um yeah or glass like
you're looking through it you're looking
through it but you're not able to
actually observe it as a state of of
your as as a state an embodied state
that you're having if you see what I
mean yeah just to unpack this one bit
for Stephen um it's kind of like without
a theory of air you could just look
forever and you could just have any
model could replace this idea about what
fills up space then there's this
chemical theory of air and there have
been various chemical theories of air
and whether there's four types of things
and they mix or whether it's protons and
neutrons and different ratios and things
like that and then once you have a
theory of air you could ask things like
well what if I compressed all of the
quote invisible stuff in this room and
all of a sudden it looks like blue or
something it's like whoa it kind of is
there there's unique experiments there's
unique predictions I'm taking something
that was transparent in the nich that
actually was real ontologically real and
then through attention and awareness and
affordances we're able to now like look
at it so we've developed projective
geometry and it's like well what if it
really were projective geometry all
along but then now with the projective
geometric tools we're coming back to
experience that and it's actually
something that Stephen and I were
talking about just this weekend with um
a little bit like what people's
experiences of perspective have been in
the past um because there is those
sometimes funny pictures um at least
comical sometimes where it's like a
person's face and it looks like it's
from a almost a Cubist angle but it's
like a Renaissance painting and there's
probably so much to say from an art
history perspective about the evolution
and the development of perspective but
at the very least it seems like people
throughout time have been differentially
excited by different types of
representations of perspective people
weren't doing photorealistic charcoal
drawings in a different era even if they
necess could have had the um
Technologies to do so so something's
happening there with perspective and how
it's changing the way that we interact
with a visual World cubism of course was
shocking and uh when it came out and so
now where are we with perspective um
there's a lot to say about that
Stephen yeah I mean one of the things
that's interesting with like imagined
feelings in space is that they can be
kind of transparent so if you like
what's the energy of someone or if I
imagine the energies of people around me
it's like a quality those qualities they
don't like if you imagine something in
space it doesn't become completely
opaque it's not like you can't see that
you're in the room anymore you know so
even if you're on stage as an actor and
you imagine that you're in a scene with
a king and it's an empty stage and you
start to imagine the whole stage you
it's still slightly transparent in
relation to the physical perceptive
conscious physical space if that makes
sense so those two things are kind of
interplaying yep yeah and and to bring
that to the affordances the field of
affordances field of Consciousness it's
like the generative model isn't just of
what the video camera would see if it
were next to your head the generative
model is actually generating this field
of action that's scaled geometrically so
that things that are closer to you and
better within reach are seemingly at
hand and things that are distant are
seemingly distant and one example that
Stephen and I were talking about was
like there might be an object on the
other side of my monitor that I'd have
to kind of go around to reach and just
right with a quick judgment it feels
like something on the other side of my
monitor is actually further away than
something that might be linearly closer
um or further away sorry but like I can
reach it directly just by reaching my
hand over I can reach two feet over with
my arm just grab it but the 18 inches
linearly to the monitor I have to end up
doing a 36 inch route so it feels longer
away so even within our atand Concepts
and the way that we talk about what is
accessible or what is um relevant these
all have to do with the grasping and the
comprehending and the action Distortion
of a space so there's really a lot here
about the perspectives that we take and
if we say there's one perspective and
it's mine there's one perspective and
it's my cultures or is it hey we're all
at this party and we're all going to
have different perspectives of this
party okay which perspectives can hang
which ones can't those are the kinds of
discussions that you get to there
instead of is it right wrong the way I'm
seeing it you know not everyone's going
to see the party like you see it because
no one's head is overlapping with your
perception because everyone's
affordances and location are different
for example
Sasha yeah I really appreciated in this
paper um the kind of connection um uh
we're always talking about on this
stream um between p uh you know taking
in information and acting um and so it's
this feedback loop of two things and I
really like this
converting uh thinking about our space
into thinking about the space of
affordances so that it's not just uh a
you know a blank slate of information
that uh you could access or not but it's
really what you are able to do with that
information and how you're going to act
on it um so I yeah I just thought that
was a really nice connection and fits in
very well with um what we're talking
about and kind of builds up this um
similar theme of how you're going to
connect action and perception cool and
just one other example that that kind of
uh made me think about it's like when
I'm dissecting an insect under a
microscope um it's very small movements
of the fingers but it in the field of
vision of a microscope will swing the
forceps like you know 30° so it'll be a
radical motion under the microscope but
it has the exact same embodiment feel as
like swinging one's arm almost as if
what matters is how much I'm seeing my
body move within a visual field and how
radical of an affordance it is like
flailing my arm versus a more fine-tuned
movement but a fine two movement with
the arm is like one inch but that's
represented by a certain number of
degrees and that ends up being like
visually almost the same number of
degrees that I can move the forceps so
even though it's at a different spatial
scale because the attention and the
affordances are down at that scale and I
have the visual um ability the umelt to
perceive at that smaller scale which
couldn't be seen if it were the nak eye
it takes on a feeling like it's in the
regular Vision regular body world and
then also the uh forceps don't have
nerves but they're sensitized so there's
a lot to say and think about there um a
few questions that I just wrote down
here just like these are of course
perennial questions they're not going to
be answered in a couple minutes but
what's exciting about studying
Consciousness what do we agree on what
do people agree on what do people
disagree on and then also what do people
agree is unknown what are the known
unknowns where might there be unknown
unknowns and then also to always return
to what is active inference doing here
what could it do here what could some
other Theory do here what do you think
Shannon yeah so your story about the
forceps in the microscope reminded me of
the first example of like extended
Consciousness that I learned about in in
a philosophy of Mind class in undergrad
and our professor was talking about
divers um who are they're not actually
diving they're in a room and they're
controlling a camera like on a on a
Little Submarine that's underwater and
they start to feel like they are the the
submarine so much so that their body is
actually responding to the the pressure
differences that they would experience
if they were diving so if the submarine
comes up very fast they'll actually feel
like they're experiencing the bends that
would happen if they were a diver coming
up so fast I don't know if this is a
true um story I've never looked it up
but it's very intriguing that your
Consciousness can be can be so extended
that you end up having these embodied
effects that you perhaps could
empirically measure if you if you were
if you had some sensors on on these
people as they were experiencing these
extended conscious moments cool
Lee um I was just going to ask Shannon
um
know whether that depends on whether the
people controlling the remote subware
have previously dived as well so they
kind of got the you know the embodied
experience as part of their model I
think for that for specifically the bz
it would or maybe they would have to
know about the B because that's a very
specific thing that doesn't happen to
your body in any other case yeah one
thing that makes me think of is like uh
the drop in a techno song when
everything's building and the tension's
building but that's actually a cultural
Reg regime of affordance and different
subg genres of Electronica or different
people who are aren't familiar with
Electronica they might get chills going
down their spine it's like oh this is
the sickest drop ever but somebody else
might just not be tuned into that regime
of attention and therefore it's like
okay wait what happened why is it just
why did the drums stop something like
that so similarly it's like the diver if
they're part of this deep generative
model and then they're they're emulating
it or they're simulating it somehow um
this diving then they may have a deeply
learned reflex about changing their
blood pressure let's just you know go
with st experiment being vaguely you
know feeling true just is that you could
if you're doing a first-person shooter
immersive video game your heart is going
to start pounding not because you need
increased blood flow that's a
psychological response so trained
psychological responses in increasingly
immersive environments like AR and VR
will generate physiological responses
and that is actually part of the thrill
that was I mean there's so much
happening here and it doesn't really go
into the AR VR here but like what if we
unprojected our projective geometry what
would happen or what about these uh sort
of Allison Wonderland type simulators
for the AR and the VR where you re you
reach towards something but your arm
moves twice as fast or you reach towards
something and your arm doesn't move and
you crash into stuff and it just feels
like you're like super disoriented or
the glasses are flipped all of these
Transformations are just super deep
interventions into the structure of
sense and action so there's a lot that
is now possible here with how we can on
fly remap these things in 1920 the
Cubist could put a light on one side of
the cube and draw it and then halfway
through the drawing move the light and
to get a different perspective and that
was kind of cool like a mashup of
perspectives in one two-dimensional
plane but now you could be experiencing
like a lot more stuff happening and the
cube could be mutating it could be hyper
Cube and stuff like that it's kind of
next level with respect to our geometry
and how it relates to our sense and
action any other thoughts or questions
here before we go to the functional
features just think of them as they come
up so the authors highlight four
functional features of Consciousness
which are Global optimization and
resilience Global availability
motivation of action and modulation of
attention and simulation enhancement so
their goals are basically these are the
things that they say it's notice that
it's very mechanism independent it
doesn't say you got to have neurons you
need Gia it doesn't say it has to be at
this time scale these are all like
things that you might say about a
cybernetic system a control theory
action perception system so these
features are the abstract functional
features of Consciousness which through
neurophenomenology will get brought into
the brain perhaps but just at the
functional level these are the functions
of Consciousness and they write we claim
that the overall fun function of
Consciousness again is it that
Consciousness is getting spun off by
systems that have these functions or is
consciousness literally the function
that Maps back into the system and gives
these features um presence in the
world we claim that the overall Fe
function of Consciousness is to address
a general cybernetic problem or problem
of control Consciousness enables again
ambiguous a situated organism with
multiple sensory channels to navigate
its environment and satisfy its
biological and derived needs efficiently
this entails minimizing and predictive
this entails minimizing predictively
erroneous representations of the world
and maximizing preference satisfaction a
good model of Consciousness must be able
to explain how this is accomplished the
PCM thus emphasizes the following
interrelated functional features of
Consciousness so ask yourself if there
was a robot that could do
Intermodal um sensory things and memory
and it was doing counterfactual
simulations and it had motivated looking
action and modulation of attention
Global availability of some variables or
some processes and it was resilient
within some resilience of course we're
not resilient to getting hit with a
hammer on the head we are resilient to
you know a train coming at us from a
mile away but not an inch away I mean
it's always going to be about where you
draw the bounds oh I mean that's out of
bounds you don't need to be resilient to
that kind of an insult to this drug but
to this molecule you are so I would just
ask if we had a robot that had some of
these features
would we include it in the conscious
club or would dennit include it in the
club no would a pan psychist yeah they
might say well it's something it's like
to be that robot but where are we really
getting if we just say it's something
it's like to be this robot and this
thermometer and this networking system
well if the only way we can ask it is
the exact same affordances that we as
observers have today like measuring
electromagnetic frequencies or something
like that then aren't we going to to be
debating these things forever because no
one really disagrees that these things
all appear to happen for systems that we
think are complex gold directed systems
like humans and cats and things like
that but isn't the question about what
else we're going to do Beyond this so
hopefully that's where the projective
geometry it's kind of like that's the uh
hook that they hang their coat on so to
speak they're going to bring it all to
projective geometry and they're going to
say this is what explains all these
functional features and the variance
which we'll get to in a second and it
makes some other predictions that would
be unique and testable so they're going
to say yeah there's probably a lot of
ways that theories of Consciousness
could explain these features like
attention schema Theory or the global
workspace Theory or integrated
information Theory all these different
Frameworks for Consciousness but we're
going to take these things and we're
going to go in a New Direction by
talking about the projective geometry so
what supports in their eyes the need for
not just a quantitative or a formal
framework but also specifically the
projective geometry and for them it's
about these phenomenological invariants
so it's kind of like Universal basic
income it's like it's Universal you know
these are invariant what part of that
don't you get so these are the things
that generalized systems of
Consciousness you could debate with them
whether these systems that they're
talking about are the right ones or
whatever but these are the invariant
features of experience and
phenomenology and they have them as
relational phenomenal intentional ity
which is that all experience and all
Consciousness is about relations
especially between one and another
system like internal and external
relationship even though as we're going
to kind of see it's a little bit
trippier than that but basically it's
about the relation of like the eye to
not I it's like I thou I I you these
kinds of things there's a situated 3D
spatiality and that means that you're
starting you're in a situated spot
you're not just everywhere experiencing
a 3D simulation but it's always
perceived as from a situated spot in
spatial dimensions three of them and
then Through Time three and four there's
this multimodal synchronic integration
which is in a snapshot it's multimodal
and then four is through time everything
is happening so this is kind of
capturing through space or through
senses and then through time saying yep
you're at a concert and there's the
light and the sound and things bumping
into you all of that is happening in
this integrated way you don't just
experience those separately um like at
the very least least the illusion
appears to cover integration across
senses which are qualitatively different
like a chemical is different than a
photon from the Sun and then there's
this temporal integration through time
which is kind of related to the
perceived event durations uh there's
messages that can be flashed on a screen
or sounds that can be outside of your uh
awareness but there's also ones that can
be within your awareness at a certain
duration of time so if it flashes for a
second it's able to be at a time scale
that's integrated into Consciousness um
there might be time scales that
influence you below that but it doesn't
become aware so like that's kind of
conscious and subconscious but it's
dealing with that um a little bit uh
blurry about whether Consciousness is
just the whole neuros system and
anything that gets integrated into the
nervous system through time is
considered to be temporally integrated
or is it that there's experiences that
actually play out over certain time
scales that we experience and then
lastly kind of related to one is this
subjective character which is that it's
about the subject and one and five are
very similar but in fact they hold that
two through five are all implicated in
one okay so they have the functional
features that's pretty abstract and
cybernetic and then they're like okay
what are the invariants almost the
axioms that we want to um be building
from that we want our Theory to be able
to address and then they're they lay
them all out one through five and then
they're like yep turns out that two
through five all collapse back onto one
so really one is the part we need to
explain in how they've set up the
problem so it's relational it's about
the relationship between the agent and
the world it's phenomenal it's based
upon experience and it deals with
intentionality and that is going to
bring in agency
affordances all these kinds of things
that have come into play okay any
thoughts on the invariance or the
functional features of Consciousness
because in a sense that's what that's
what frames the paper and it's what
frames the discussion the kinds of
answers they're going to come to is
these are their checklist for how
they'll know they'll succeed or this is
the recipe these are the ingredients
this is like what they're cooking with
for the paper so if anyone thinks of it
they can raise their hand I just want to
clarify that because it's like you could
think about this stuff all day but at
least for a journal Club it's like what
did the authors actually specify to do
did they answer something that um yeah
so
Stephen um yeah I suppose also coming
back to what Lee was saying about um
perceiving things in terms of our
cognition in relation to our history I
when we started getting into perspective
painting and thinking about things that
way you get this sense of how much is it
about us
[Music]
constructing cognition
as a cultural way of being how much are
we actually constructing this relational
phenomenal
intentionality culturally and that then
because in indigenous cultures you see
they think a lot more about shape
shifting and the land being much more
fluid and
infolded um whereas we tend to have it
much more linear and structured and
straight edged so there's there's some
question there about how much this
Consciousness becomes like a construct
that we actually put on the world yeah
one um researcher who's done a lot there
is the professor Tanya lurman and
collaborators at Stanford and she
studies um like hearing voices in
various uh cultures and so what is the
difference between a society that says
hey the voices that you hear are your
ancestors and they're telling you cool
stuff or it's a mole thing and it's all
random or it's bad voices that are
actually getting into your head that is
going to be shading the experience of
the people experiencing voices and so
when we're talking about Consciousness
what if one Society they tell everyone
and multi-generations it's completely
baked into their culture it's like yeah
it's an illusion you know denit toia
everybody it's an illusion and just the
ideas that come to your head they're
they're literally defined by being
illusory and you're you're basically
just in this Perpetual Auto gaslighting
scenario just don't don't worry about
the policies we're pushing on you just
go with it and then another culture says
actually the spark of awareness is what
should be followed even if it appears to
disassociate from social norms that's
going to be a different outcome and so
all of those different cultures could
contain individuals that are 100%
convinced that they're right so being
right isn't the same thing or thinking
you're right isn't the same thing as
having an answer to the Consciousness
question and yeah there's a lot of
implications with how we actually are
constructing our world and our
perspective so that is very related to
Lee's point I think he's Frozen for a
second but yeah I agree that was a
really good point about how um it's like
we're in feedback we're doing Niche
modification for how we perceive and
what affordances we have in the
Consciousness space if you train up
people in a Insight Meditation tradition
since they're children or something
they're going to have affordances in
their Consciousness uh it's another
framework good or bad layer on top of
that with the Judgment but they're
depending on what people are taught
about their consciousness is growing up
that is going to color their experience
and what affordances and what
trajectories they take later on um so
very interesting stuff and I wonder like
what the authors think about that or how
they conceptualize these issues so just
to cover this projective geometry bit
because they WR the concept of 4D
four-dimensional projective
transformation is Central to the model
as it yields an account of the link
between perception imagination and
multi-point of view action planning so
they're going to try to link some of the
cool stuff like we've talked about in
this action perception Loop we've asked
where is Imagination where is um
Imagination and speculation and all
these different things that we appear or
experience engaging in and then also how
do we Square the circle with the fact
that we're so situated in our
affordances yet we can also Imagine
things that aren seemingly uh related to
our affordances like a city's grid it
doesn't seem like it's tied directly to
my affordances of course in a traveling
sense it is but not like it doesn't
depend on where I'm sitting in my
building in a different city so geometry
is about um the shape and the size of
things whereas topology is about how
they're connected so in topology we talk
a lot about nodes and edges and about
connectedness and structure whereas in
Geometry structures related to angles
and sides and edges and things like that
and ukian geometry is kind of like
linear algebra is a specific uh case of
geometry where certain prerequisites are
true like parallel lines don't intersect
and the angles of a triangle are
180° there are non- ukian geometries
just like there are non-linear models
and non- ukian geometries which is kind
of like the outgroup to the exclusion of
ukian so it includes a vast number of
esoteric geometries and the way that you
can move from some geometries to other
geometries is through a projection and
that projection is called a map so it's
kind of like seeing the map that's in
front of you it's like it's a map it
Maps your representation onto the
territory so this is like a map that
Maps one territory onto a different
territory or one geometric projection of
a of a territory onto another so you
could map between two different kinds of
maps of the world you can map between a
flat one and a spherical one with
certain distortions taken along and
things like that but the key
mathematical features are that in the
ukian Paradigm there aren't special
points um there aren't points at
Infinity it just is like a vast plane
that doesn't end there's no Horizon
there might be a angle of vision that
you can't resolve below but there isn't
a horizon in a flat plane and then the
the origin is arbitrary in that every
point you choose you could just say oh
well this is you know 0 00 0 and the um
local neighborhood is exactly the same
here as it is everywhere else it's all
square contrast it with non- ukian
geometries which are like you can
imagine though there are many non-an
types have features that include things
like special point point or points at
Infinity like there is a ring of points
at infinity and they're all equally
infinite far away there can be Horizons
there's um non-arbitrary Origins all
this kind of stuff and they're basically
going right the perspectival phenomenal
space so our perspective of what we're
experiencing in a geometric
understanding allows us to locate
ourselves and navigate in an ambient
space that is nevertheless essentially
ukian so you can be in a 90° room but
you can be having this like wacky
distorted hyperbolic experience of this
90° room and kind of seamlessly
integrating across that even if it was a
bunch of Cubes that were connected you
can climb through it you can navigate in
this idian world and um measure the
angles they're 90° it's all ukian but
your perception is still going to have
this distorted effect where things
closer to you are um seemingly different
than things further from you and that
means that the angles as you look at
them unless you're in a very specific
Position will not look like 90° look
around the room you're in even the
corners don't look like 90° um and they
basically say because um the ukian space
has no privileged points no points at
Infinity no Horizon no non-arbitrary
origin it very strongly suggests that a
non- ukian frame must be operating with
a help of sensory motor calibrations to
preserve the sense of invariance of
objects across the multiple perspectives
adopted and relate the situated organism
to the ambient ukan space so like put
your hand on a 90° angle you can pretty
much feel from propri reception it's 90°
you look down it's not 90° feels normal
everything's chill because we're
experiencing this Distortion of the
ukian space okay any thoughts on the
projective geometry or about geometry or
where would geometry fit into a
Consciousness
model I just concur with them that
there's some functional attributes that
would Point towards non- ukian spaces
but then every time like wait what in
the how with geometry just how is it
giving us experience again I guess
that's sort of the uh the question but
uh yeah
Sasha um yeah I also thought this was
really trippy um I really liked uh the
9.0 kind of pre uh pre-digestion of this
uh topic so I found that really helpful
um yeah I think this is kind of trying
to walk us through um the possible you
know points of view on uh Consciousness
that um not only does each individual
have a different perspective
um necessarily in ukian space um like
we're all seeing it from different
locations let's say but that even the
the mapping is different between
individuals onto our own non-
ukian you know projection of uh
experience and so I I think that's
that's kind of many steps to walk
through to recognize how different
um we see the world and how we can
define this word perspective so I think
that is really uh an important aspect of
understanding Consciousness is uh where
individual perspective is baked into the
whole process yep and it makes me think
about like um let me see it through your
perspective or do you see it how I see
it so we have visual metaphors for
alignment and then we have put you know
walk a mile in someone else's shoes or
put yourself in their shoes those are
embodied and active metaphors of
understanding what else someone's
experience is like and then what we're
saying here is um somehow we should
should integrate that how you see it and
how you walk it together so that your
perspective is based upon both how you
see it and the shoes that you're walking
in so your actual embedded extended body
and how you walk in those shoes and
there's people for whom they can't walk
a mile in any shoes so what are other
metaphors that help us go beyond just
simple walking to really understand that
more generally we're talking about like
perception and action and that because
perception and action are linked in US
in fact perspectively Linked In us it's
also that way in someone else's so it's
not just about coming to agreement with
what they think or believe or state they
believe nor is it about specifically
reenacting their action sequences which
we wouldn't either be able to do or
wouldn't even have the same perspective
on them as they do how are we going to
collaborate and so there's like a lot of
interesting stuff and I would hope that
this provides a little bit more
structure to sometimes discussions about
everything from
issues people disagree on to
accessibility how could we whether we um
bring in projective geometry or not how
could we just start with the idea that
everyone is going to have a unique
perspective and then work for uh
something Collective rather than get to
this point where it's like well we
disagree okay well now what um yeah Alex
go
ahead uh yeah I just wanted to say this
this brings up uh it it reminds me of
general relativity in a way um like
conscious is some sort of
uh
fundamental it's
a if two folks are in different
perspectives uh and they can observe the
order of events occurring in different
ways are
in if they can uh observe events uh
occurring out of order based on their
perspective and a third
remote uh thing that they're looking at
uh maybe Consciousness is the way of
uh self
observant uh of a larger system when uh
the system
is essentially a manifold uh
uh
the Consciousness is the uh recognition
of Relativity in actual space right um
and this projective geometry seems to
kind of be getting there um if we are
unable to observe the entire world and
we're only able to observe from our
perspective uh Consciousness is the
recognition that that is an a variant
across space and other agents uh should
have the
same uh I don't know phenomena I
apologize
for terminality obiously no that's
that's awesome I I I really like this
you you said the recognition of general
relativity is consciousness and so in
ukian bace it's like the invariant is
angle's going to sum to 360 and this is
going to work this way and the parallel
okay so those are geometrical invariants
but because the world is so
quintessentially perspectival and
embedded in an active actually the
invariant is this relationship of um
action and perception and that you move
in a apparently non- ukian space because
the invariant is actually like the locus
of what is generating awareness is um
Consciousness and then the two examples
that came to mind are first off you hear
a noise with each ear at a different um
time and you hear you know in photons
probably know hit lights at your eyes at
different times but also they see
different things but you get a monocular
perception from two different eyes and
you know but you can push one eye you
can violate an expectation and you can
see two images but basically when it
works it's monocular and then I was
thinking of a concert where like the
base is on one side and the treble
speakers are on the other and then it's
like the group they're actually hearing
the events in a different order one
person hears one note before the other
one and vice versa but especially
locally that doesn't mean it's
incoherent so what is happening there
and that's kind of like this group
Consciousness question and just thanks
for bringing it to the general
relativity level because also with the
general relativity um Innovation it was
a movement from a cartisian Newtonian
ukian all these things um movement
towards like yeah maybe gravity isn't
like a nonlinear Force operating on a
ukian field but rather it is a non-
ukian distortion of another thing and so
there's really a lot to say there and
then also there's like a lot of inroads
to Quantum and Consciousness whether
it's ham uh hammer off and Penrose and
about the work on microtubules or
whether it's just other more broader
physics grounded theories there's so
much there about where Quantum itself
might fit in so a lot of points of
contact there with non- ukian geometry
perspective and um and then the fact
that we don't overlap with any other
system in terms of our perspective and
so then how do we take that and it's
like well just like you can build a
computer in a world with general
relativity can't we design information
and sensemaking and attention systems
that work in a world where people have
different perspectives I'd hope so
Stephen yeah I like this like really
broadening the idea of relationships
because I think what's really helpful
with this diagram is it and talking
about the map as a way of projecting
between types of spaces rather than this
idea of projection as representations in
the mind being projected on the world
which it's kind of the slight danger
with that language you know because it
gets used in that um in that rep
representational way if it's
somehow the way that we
engage a type of spatial Arrangement
almost bringing in spatial cognition
work but bringing it much more into the
body um and I think this relates maybe
some of the work with Harry heft he does
some really interesting work in the
world of spatial cognition um and it'd
be interesting to see his perspective on
this yeah what you said about projection
so that's like in the Psychotherapy it's
like you're not seeing it how it is
you're projecting you're you're know
you're you're um you're envisioning
you're biased you're projecting onto the
world you're projecting that emotions
onto them but it's like what if you
start from hey it is a projection you
are in a projection you are the pro
projection your experience is the
projection of all these things that
we're talking about so it's like let's
start from that point of view that
you're not treating this person like a
robot you're assuming they're having
emotions so you're engaged in this
relational projection that's intentional
about your relationship so how could we
connect for example optimism about the
relationship to how you are going to map
their facial expression onto your
behavior not onto what do they think but
on how you're going to act in a certain
situation that's a pretty uh different
context so I think that's like a very uh
interesting to bring the psychological
projection the almost the
psychotherapeutic use of the term to
geometric progression uh and and I'm
sorry geometric projection and then
connecting non- ukian geometric
projections to to
um general relativity and to control
theory and about systems design all
these different
things so just a few quotes that we can
kind of go through here um basically
this is just a a summary of what they
believe the pcm's strengths are and how
they summarize it which is that the
structure geometrically of multimodal
lived conscious experience closely
approximates a projective three space so
that's like a threedimensional space
with kind of this geometer's lingo
on which a projective transformation I
believe pgl4 is saying it's a
four-dimensional projection projected
down but we could hear from a geometer
with a little bit more information here
or what would the physics Community
notate this as our model fits intuitive
data but it also helps account for other
phenomena that might seem at first
unconnected including working
perspectival imagination inferences
about the points of view and aims of
others uh like the intentional stance
modulo uh active inference and many
peculiar phenomena associated with
Consciousness so OB Out of Body
Experience hiatos scopy D realization
Oceanic and mystical experiences it also
sheds light on some visual phenomena
which we'll definitely get to and it
sounds like there's a bunch of papes and
they're probably writing more so if any
of the authors want to you know share
what they're thinking or doing now
that's cool here is an example we talked
about a little earlier which is that
when we consider like think about the
Empire State Building we think about it
um in perspective like looking up at the
P at the Empire State Building or just
floating away far away so that it
basically looks ukian because it's far
away but it's going to be both
conceptualized independently of any
particular point of view like you could
zoom in in your little brain AutoCAD
simulator and imagine yourself on the
40th floor looking at a 90° angle in an
ie beam and you wouldn't have any um
deception that it's actually ukian 90°
but then at the same time we can
naturally co-experience almost this like
looking up at it and understanding that
no it's still not going to look 90° so
that's what optimally allows with this
projection the perspectival accessing of
ukian models of the world in memory for
appraisal and updating of such models
through active sampling so we get to
benefit from the sort of statistical uh
uh reality realism let's say at least
not reality of having a model that's
actually rect linear for example but
then also have this total fluid
projection that allows us to act and
perspectiv perspectively understand
oursel in that space so there's the
relative perception and then there's
that perspective independent objective
knowledge based which doesn't mean it's
correct it just means that it's about an
object it's of an object it's not truth
objectivity it's objective like it's
about this box on my desk and productive
geometry helps functionally connect
subjectivity so being about the subject
that's relational and then epistemic
objectivity again not truth just
knowledge about objects allowing us to
see Consciousness as a kind of mediator
between the situated organism and the
objective World it inhabits very cool
stuff they also right so Active Vision
thus becomes like a palpation of a 3D
spatial user surface to feel the
epistemic affordances that are
Quantified by expected free energy this
anticipatory palpation with temporal
depth requires a generative model that
encompasses the consequences of actions
and their effective values so in some
other work by friston and colleagues
where they've looked at for example
reading and informational foraging with
the ocular motor with the eye muscles
and so the way that the eye scans around
the page it's not based upon maximal
reward it's based upon the maximally
informative observation that could be
made and what is that observation
maximally informative in the framework
of well top down priors about semantics
so when somebody's coming towards you
there's like subconscious icade
movements that first assess for example
the um broad category of person that it
belongs to and then they will zoom in on
different components of the face and
culturally informed areas of the face
that might signal different types of
things like um whether there's going to
be a good relationship in the uh future
or not and so it is so interesting what
the authors did which is to tie this
information foraging optimal foraging
info foraging info thermodynamics
perspective take it from the cybernetics
where it already had been very well
entrenched and now say like that's our
experience of vision that's why even
when your eyes are cating at the level
that you're actually perceiving it's
actually a lot smoother because our
experience is sort of smoothed out over
those underlying Cades that being said
those Cades are driven in a top- down
way as a compromise with top down forces
let's say by culturally informed priors
your eyes won't know how to scan if you
don't know how to read the language you
won't know which parts the letter
informative which parts the word but
when you're fluent in the language then
we know that like all the letters in the
middle can be mixed up
because you're really just doing a
generative model of the text and that
turns out that it includes information
about font and includes sentence
structure all these other things you
can't understand the sentence with the
words mixed up in a different order if
the letters are in the right order but
the words are mixed the semantics don't
allow the top down to inform the bottom
up so your visual foraging is bunk
because you're going to be looking at
the difference between a b and a d but
you're not going to understand what the
sentence's meaning is because that's
level we're actually at
this framing of expected free energy
through projective transformation in
imagination provides a method for
envisioning how things would look feel
or be from another hopefully better
location and thus guide action so like
where would I be looking at if I were
figuring out what this word were under
my generative assumptions about
language it is important to emphasize
that according to the projective
Consciousness model free energy
minimization is always operating as the
fundamental algorithm governing the
field of Consciousness and thus there's
never an end to the process as there is
never in practice a solution that
reduces free energy to zero which
because it's defined as this
informational distance against a
non-stationary uh realism world uh it
means that basically it's always going
to be bounded by zero and he this I
thought was very funny heel might be
happy to know that on the projective
Consciousness model Consciousness is
thus always somehow unhappy even when it
reaches the best possible States
available to it so this is the uh
wellknown
hegelian dialectic of thesis antithesis
synthesis often shown as a loop as if it
were just this runaround rock paper
scissor here it's actually like a
virtuous or a vicious spiral and it just
showing how this semantic ordering of
events with thesis antithesis and
synthesis it's like it never ends free
energy minimization optimization
cybernetic control processes multiscale
evolutionary adaptive systems they don't
end they can't take a break there can be
relaxing times but they can't rest in
the actual like stasis there can be
stasis with respect to a certain
Dimension but that's reflected by this
seething activity that actually
structures the strange attractor so that
the system returns to these homeostatic
preferred expected and optimal States
and if you prefer over evolutionary time
something that isn't optimal or isn't
functional you're not going to exist
that model will not exist of the
statistical regularities in their Niche
because their preferences the
observations they seek out will include
things like toxins or jumping off of
cliffs these are not adaptive
observations uh inter receptively or
from a visual perspective and so you end
up not seeing models that prefer those
things and so it's like this endless
preference hunt policy adaptive
selection stuff happening um
pretty cool stuff by the authors any
thoughts before we just look through the
figures before we close out
see you sash thank you so just to spend
a couple minutes on each figure and just
see what they kind of do and then maybe
we could either reach out to the author
or just everybody who's listening to
this treat it as an open call to come
participate if you're curious about this
or something does or doesn't add up
let's hear about it cool so figure one
is this account of psychological
phenomena and I think uh it's almost
like Minecraft helps us understand their
simulations so let's just imagine that
they're doing this in Minecraft so in
the a is like the Builder mode of
Minecraft which ironically is still from
a perspective even though they're trying
their hardest to represent a ukan world
it turns out that can only be done from
like the position of a camera wherever
that camera is there's no location
independent representation of this ukian
space unless they did like just a matrix
and they said look just render it
yourself but when you rendered it it
would have to be from a perspective you
can't have all the perspectives at once
or flattening in a dimension that
doesn't uh work like that but then the
lived space S2 which is um they're using
geometric notation I'm not totally sure
about it maybe again a geometer could
come on but like basically what they're
saying is even if you have this block of
interest when you put a person's head
there or their gener the locus of their
generative model um they're going to see
things in this distorted way B is the
anti-space beyond the plane at Infinity
so I don't know exactly what it is but
it's and it was interesting they said
with a transparent plane at Infinity so
it's actually bringing this like
transparent uh notion back but this is
like it's the opposite of what you see
in some way I I guess it's like it's the
yeah it's everything what you don't see
it's like when you're watching the
sunset what is not being seen and maybe
is the anti-space and then this um God's
eye projection are like somehow a
transformation of the space that
includes a lot of the planes of symmetry
they write almost all the space is
visible but completely warped and the
world model manifest as structures with
complex symmetries so that's quite
interesting because whether you agree
with it being God's eye or not I would
say it's just another projection of the
system um or just another at least as
we're seeing it but maybe it's in like a
ton of Dimensions or it has like other
trippy features but this is kind of like
highlighting just the uh the the
invariances of the visual field but that
doesn't guide action like if you're a
baseball player and you're running
towards the ball maybe there's like you
know the one symmetry would be all the
grass when you look down and all the
Blue Sky when you look up and then
there's a ball and that's like breaking
the Symmetry in some very nuanced way in
a dynamic way but what do you want to
actually see as the ball comes towards
you well it's actually what we do see
which is that the ball gets bigger and
apparently more manipulatable and we can
do increased resolution on things like
it speed when it's further away that
helps us um estimate where to go but
it's close we can fine tune so it's like
exactly what you would want as an
embedded agent is what we're
experiencing and so we're not
experiencing this like whoa it's just
like hidden symmetries nor are we
experiencing like the Minecraft or the
Grand Theft Auto perspective we're in
our own embedded situated experience
relationally engaging with affordances
and the field of Consciousness and the
field of affordances are very
related interesting stuff great rep
presentations at very least just stuff
to think about and learn this one I
thought was very informative so this is
a que um we can think of this visual
illusion as a q that's ambiguous so it's
called The necer Cube and basically
depending on how you see it cough cough
you can either see the bigger wider side
as like pointing up into the left which
is left and right already are relational
spatial and down and to the right so
it's like you know which way let's just
let's just have a quick show of hands
raise your hand if in looking at either
of both of these option one is going to
be I see it um basically going up to the
left two is down to the right and three
is it switches for me okay option one
who sees it go up and to the left
primarily okay option two who sees it go
down into the right
primarily and then who sees it just like
rapidly
fluctuating okay
yeah I'd say it seems like people raise
their hand in every category small
sample size but yes it's an illusion
it's something that is ambiguous and the
reason why is it's a three-dimensional
Cube at least it suggests it hints at
being a threedimensional cube but of
course it just lines on a page okay we
unpack that in a very generous
optimistic way as being a
two-dimensional drawing of a cube if a
child drew that you'd say the child is
trying to draw a cube they're not
drawing like a logo with like you know a
double helix and two you know it
suggests a cube it hints at a cube but
it's a two-dimensional projection onto a
piece of paper well duh but it turns out
that without shading one of the sides or
adding a light which implies a
perspective it's like you can flip
between these two solutions so to speak
of how to represent it and so u in
relation to this cube is actually this
ambiguity that's being um flipped back
and forth between and then specific um
situations might cause it to um prefer
one side or the other yeah Lee what do
you think about
that well I think this I mean I'm really
interested in this because it kind of
relates to um to the the point about
unconscious simulations
so if you're looking at it and and it
flips which it can which it can do and
it does do if you start to pay more
attention to that you you realize that
it doesn't just flip there's a sense in
which there's um there's a kind of an
unconscious doing which is probably I'm
assuming to do with the predictions that
you're making so you know if I pay
really close attention what I notice is
that I'm isolating
uh or tracing maybe different portions
of the cube in different ways and then
labeling them in different ways so I
kind of go oh that's a you know if this
bits is a corner or that's the front or
that's the back so and it's that that
actually makes it kind of shift and I
think it points to this idea you know
like of that the you know the perceptual
world is is kind of a
co-construction in a way but it's it's
the it's that I suppose what I'm
interested in is that it's a it's a kind
of a doing you know there's a there's a
way in which we're active in it which is
more often than not transparent you know
we don't necessarily so for example a
more real world example might be um you
know if we look at a tree we might label
it an object you know typically we do
but um but actually it's kind of more of
a it's more of a process but we don't we
don't see it that way because we just
kind of you know we look at it and you
know for all intents and purposes if
it's not Salient to us we wouldn't
notice that but anyway yeah well no it's
super interesting and the semantics and
the illusion it's like there's the old
woman young woman illusion um and then
there's like the Bunny and the uh duck
and those the semantic level can be like
I'm looking at a bunny and then you'll
basically not see the duck as much okay
so the semantics can inform us
especially when you label for Action
like this is the side with a handle all
of a sudden be like no I can feel it
dragging I'm only seeing now one of
those two sides fixed I'm keeping my
eyes right where I want the handle to be
and all of a sudden it feels easier to
keep it in one zone and then also it's
like there's illusions that are super
ambiguous for some people and other
people like I'm sorry I just don't see
the young woman in that illusion I just
don't see the bunny I don't know what
you're I don't see that dress as that
color remember that whole thing so
that's like because of the subconscious
you know the iceberg of the actual
neurophenomenology the underpinnings and
the mechanisms some people are near a
critical transition point in their
perception where just by scanning their
eyes the ballerina will flip one way or
the other other people because of how
their deep priors guide their visual
foraging and their info gener and their
information foraging and their by
generation of model they just will never
be able to have the ballerina switch
directions never never be able to have
the duck go one way if you haven't seen
a duck you're not going to see it in the
back of the head of a bunny yeah
Stephen yeah I saw an interesting
presentation by bur Lotto he does some
work down in Neuroscience with cir to
Cay actually and he showed this picture
I think it was fairly similar picture
and he said that we mostly see it from
above because we expect to see things
from above first which I thought was
kind of interesting so there's kind of
like you do end up with this kind of
inactive situated piece because it's
like well I'm sucking sunic here I'm
probably looking from above if I'm
looking from above these things pop out
then well maybe it's um so you know I
thought that was kind of that reminds me
of children's cereal being put lower on
the aisle to get them in their zone of
affordances it's in their proximal zon
so you can do niche-based partitioning
of surveillance capitalism great I love
it and then also uh there's a lot of
other uh natural situations where we can
track what an animal looks at and yeah
they're looking at things that are
actionable and that's like us grabbing
something from the top there's not maybe
foraging for branches you don't
visualize it from the top but that's
something that we can do but really we
specialize on picking up things that
were above okay let's look at just this
last two figures so figure three I think
is uh related to this uh paper 2018
paper that they mentioned in the very
end for more details on this family of
simulations but essentially it's showing
like multiple views of the uh
expectation map and the prior belief map
and basically an agent has to move from
the left side to the right side so like
it moves from here's its left here it
starting and it has to move through its
pit I don't know if that's a bad state
or what about it but basically here it
is blue it believes there's a goal over
here it's going to pierce into this
darker blue with its zone of prox
awareness essentially move through the
pit resolve uncertainty about what
actions to take here the action path is
simple just keep walking in a straight
line um even though it looks like narrow
and you're then finally it gets in
contact with the uh goal State purple
and so from its local geometrically uh
distorted point of view projected point
of view there's a free energy
thermometer and it's like first it scans
around and then it's like okay I'm going
to go that way towards the goal and
reduce my uncertainty and then it's just
getting lit up and that's interesting in
ly where dopamine comes into play it's
something I would love to talk about
soon because I've worked on dopamine the
free energy principle perspective dopes
usually thought about as a reward
molecule oh it makes you happy or it's
the reward you know slot machines and
all that but if we think about it in
this context dopamine firing patterns in
this phase anticipatory of the reward
actually have to do with free energy and
um when you get to the reward your
Precision is confirmed because you
already believe there was a reward there
so actually and this is shown in figure
four as you approach the max zone of
maximal information uncertainty
reduction that's when the free energy is
uh getting out of control so to speak
and then when the goal is achieved
Precision is achieved again so when we
think about what the neurophysiology
actually is and how different
interventions in our neurophysiology
might map on to differences in what
about somebody who doesn't have
motivation even though they know the
goal is right here but they're just just
not even if they can see there and other
people say it's well lit you can just do
it and they just don't have the
motivation maybe someone else is here
and they go actually I like the other
side more or all these different things
without passing judgment on what these
states are what level of analysis or
what culture says they're rewarded or
not just how can we map some of these
cybernetic parameters onto the neuro and
eventually the phenomenological
parameters and I think figure four gets
out a lot of similar ideas because it's
talking about this relationship between
the lived space and the peripersonal
space one might almost be able to say
and also events that are perceived or
imagined and that surprisal and then
reduction of uncertainty the sort of
realignment reordering of either action
or the inference side to reduce surprise
about the world given this very deep
generative model um that's kind of where
it's at and those were some really cool
ideas brought up in the paper and just
if anyone else wants to raise their hand
just a few more interesting notes on
this figure I thought were cool they
show a loop from um prediction to the uh
perception to prediction of the change
in free energy imagination and then
action and so we've been talking a lot
about cycles that go like perception
action world right perception agent
action world like that but here this is
a a loop that happens in an organism or
in a model of analysis still it's a
nested marov situation and it doesn't
replace the other one it's not the other
one the other one is about agents in the
world and this is actually like saying
in these reflexive conscious
systems what is actually the loop that
allows imaginated imaginated events to
influence action so I I don't know if
this is and it shows which directions
different things can influence each
other here it has perception and action
influencing each other so maybe that's
the other world in the agent Loop but
then here's these other processes
playing out just very cool and then
here's like the vector of time on a free
energy landscape through time and it's
projected and it's going downhill so to
speak through time in this like vector
weird way and as I understand it and I
barely understand it that's where the
math and the research is is it's like
okay chemical reactions always go
downhill well a candle burning is still
downhill okay what about a cell well a
cell is also downhill in a really
specific way well all of our policy
actions are downhill in what landscape
that's the free energy optimization how
is the landscape changing that's a
relationship of how are meta
optimization proceeds amidst different
kinds of environmental regularities so
um yeah that's all I would say about
these figures before we close anyone
else have any last thoughts what what
would be something to go into more in
9.2 yep let's do um Alex and then
Stephen uh I'll try to be brief um uh it
it's interesting to me like relating
this to the free energy principle that
you model these Dynamic systems as
agents which are trying to uh export
energy from their identity
um uh by performing action in Greater
system that they're a part of uh their
action actually creates new unknowns
that they have to perceive and solve uh
and maybe cognition is just the boundary
between
direct feedback and the larger
environment they are part of like maybe
it is the self-referential like
structure that necessarily creates
itself cool I don't know cool awesome
thoughts
Stephen yeah just thanks for unpacking
these diagrams because I I had looked at
this paper a fair bit once in the past
but some of this stuff was really hard
to so this is this is really helpful um
I I think this idea of the that that
there is this
imagination that's going on is really
useful and I I think I don't know how
many other papers really deal with this
so I think that's quite quite
interesting and one bit in the paper
that we might want to think about that I
did notice is this this it does say in
the paper Sun about how this doesn't try
and deal with all the subconscious
Dynamics underneath but that that is
about trying to find this kind of extra
layer of conscious imagination or
projection so it might be interesting
just to explore that next
time cool thanks for the suggestion and
everyone thanks a lot for participating
we will have follow-up forms for the
participants it's in your calendar
invite and uh via that mechanism for the
live participants or just a Twitter
Youtube comment for anyone else please
provide us with feedback suggestions
questions we'll be able to go into them
for 9.2 good groundwork today and then
yeah 9.2 we'll be able to talk a lot
more hopefully here from a bunch of
different perspectives um and just stay
in communication with Team Comm it was a
great discussion really thanks everyone
for participating it's just like super
fascinating stuff so thanks again for
the conversation and we will talk next
week everybody who's hearing it you're
welcome to join next week or the
following week but thanks again
everybody and we'll uh see you later
oh